richard
l'émission est terminée
il est l'heure de quelques questions un
petit peu plus personnelle c 130
personnels je peux te les envoyer dans
l'ue mais commis à la grille ne risque
pas grand chose encore 10 mois bohringer
weir dix ans tu crois pas que tu es le
roi des démagos
aaa comme ça me plaît ça et ça me plaît
le roi des démagos non je ne suis pas un
avion je suis pas démago non je sais que
ça se dit mais je
n'arrive pas à savoir vraiment si ce mot
et est péjoratif aussi on l'a rendue
pèsera jésus
voulait dire mon cher ardisson que
j'aurai une tendance à avoir l'amour du
genre humain je dis rien j'écoute avoir
les jambes oui j'ai l'amour des gens
mais à partir de ce moment là si je le
crie trop fort si on appelle ça être le
roi des démagos bat tant qu'ils sont les
autres qui l'ont pas entendu les
battements de mon coeur est ce que c'est
parce que tu es capricorne comme les
sucres et que tu passes ton temps à
vouloir refaire le monde on savait que
c'était une chose là le jour où
il m'a été révélé que jésus-christ était
du premier des candidats tricorps jeu
j'ai cru que c'était
une blague vous rêvez détonne capricorne
et geslin politique et l'enjeu aussi et
après quoi
c'est pour ça que tu me passes ton temps
refaire le monde
c'est peut-être parce que parce que je
l'aimais tellement souvent que
j'aimerais bien qu'il soit un bon une
fois pour toutes alors chacun y va avec
sa petite ruelle moi je jette un grand
mondial voilà merci c'est pas de
ristourne brathwaite chat
jacques c'est la première fois que vous
entrez dans un confessionnal oui quel
effet cela vous fait
je vous dirais que j'aime beaucoup
l'atmosphère des églises l'atmosphère du
sacré et
donc ça me fait le même effet vous êtes
déjà allongé sur le divan d'un psy quête
d'un petit quart d'heure même pour
rigoler pour rigoler mais avec des gens
qui n'étaient pas aussi
ma mère n'avait pas besoin de porter
l'étoile jaune elle était jaune de la
tête aux pieds c'est cette sensibilité
de colonisés qui a guidé votre vie je
crois oui c'est pour ça que j'avais
défendu barbie non pas comme
tortionnaire nazi mais comme membres
d'une armée d'occupation
comme l'armée française en algérie où
l'armée américaine au vietnam où l'armée
russe en afghanistan pour moi à barbie
est un personnage tragique de notre
temps celle officier subalterne d'une
armée d'occupation dans un pays qui
résiste
vous avez dit comme roger nimier tout
humanisme et étrangers expliquez vous
je veux dire ceci c'est que
il y à une certaine morale
qui se cache derrière les mots humaniste
derrière les mots droits de l'homme qui
exprime le l'état de la société en
europe à l'heure actuelle
cette morale cette vision du monde qui
n'aimait pas général d'ailleurs est le
résultat du lycée est l'aboutissement
d'une histoire
et je trouve que vouloir imposer cette
vision du monde à tous les pays à toutes
les nations c'est faire fi de leurs
cultures différentes de leur histoire
différents de leur vision du monde qui
est différente c'est manifestement
n'avoir pas du spengler
est ce que vous auriez défendu adolf
hitler
s'il était venu me voir et qu'il m'avait
dit je suis certainement l'homme dans
l'histoire du monde
qui est l'objet des accusations les plus
graves je crois que c'est incontestable
mon procès et fed avancent c'est encore
une cause perdue mais parmi les millions
d'avocats qui en allemand que je pense
que vous êtes le seul capable de donner
à mes actes leur vraie signification
leur vraie dimension sur une entente
m'excuser je vous demande de
le décrire afin de donner à ma vie sa
dîme sa véritable dimension à ce moment
là je crois que j'aurais accepté pendant
les six ans vous avez disparu vous étiez
où quelque part vous dirai jamais
vous savez les liaisons qu'elle soit
amoureuse aux politiques qu'on cache
sont toujours les plus
ça vous fait mal d'être un écrivain raté
d'abord écrivain raté il aurait fallu
que je sois allé j'ai la volonté d'être
écrivain je suis un livre c'est l agenda
que ça c'est assez longue ça dépend et
comme on le prend mais le ce que je veux
dire c'est le travail d'avocat dans
comme je conçois est un travail de
création aussi avec son originalité
c'est quoi la beauté du crime
la beauté du crime c'est cela ne veut
pas dire que tous les crimes sont beaux
la beauté du greaves et que certains
crimes
prennent une signification universelle
est-ce que vous avez le sens du péché
non
seamine tu ne sais pas si tu es le fils
d'un arabe d'un juif d'un militaire
français si tu pouvais choisir tu
choisirais quoi
[Musique]
justement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est justement je ne venais pas choisir
maintenant
je vis farhad catholique et
je peux aujourd'hui affirmé quand un
côté les uns catalytiques ont ils échos
quand un juif est con il est con et
quand on aura des cons il est qu'on
imagine qu'un jour il y ait une nouvelle
guerre entre la france et l'algérie tu
serais de quel côté je me situerais du
côté de la raison est ce que tu te
souviens du jour où tu as le plus
détesté un français de france lui est
français
moi je dis toujours devant les copains
où je rencontre devant les potes et
tunisiens mais les français sont
racistes
je pense que la france n'est pas
essentiellement raciste d'espoir que je
reprochais d'information de banaliser et
généralisée puis il faut pas généraliser
il faut se dire que la france est la
france des différences et des
dans les différences d'opinion et les
les différences d'avis et on vit et
démocratie ça ça veut dire moins le pen
il existe il est là
il doit vivre justement une doit à lille
d'où il doit exister dans la mesure où
on fait partie du jeu démocratique
je crois que
la qualité de la france justement comme
la qualité de l'amérique c'est justement
d'avoir ce brassage de différence grâce
à ce brassage d'identité qui fait
vraiment la force la force d'un pays le
couscous c'est très très bon le plus
cool et vous vous n'hésitez pas à venir
manger dans les restaurants - toulouse
parce que tout le monde dit c'est bon
couscous à couscous et arabes le
couscous et j imagine qu un jour tu es
dans un petite ville ou un village les
gens savent pas que tu aies smaïn et que
quelqu'un te traite de sale arabe je lui
réponds quoi j'éclate de rire toi qui a
été choisi par une bonne soeur soeur
cécile au milieu de tous les orphelins
de saint vincent de paul à constantine
et qui avait pu parce que tu as été
adopté par des parts des cabines vivant
en france à voir la vie que tu as est-ce
que tu ne vois pas derrière tu dis
l'étoile mais pourquoi ne pas y voir
dieu directement pour peut encore se
cacher derrière ce duo
est ce que tu crois pas pour finir que
tu as peur de croire en dieu
non puisque j'y crois c'est ce que tu
t'es déjà confessé oui beaucoup on était
petit quand j'étais à partir de ma
profession de foi gtv par les soeurs
j'étais au
l'institut de jeunes filles saint joseph
jaffres et les bonnes manières est-ce
que tu approuve le divorce
oui oui je trouve ça plutôt bien de se
séparer si on ne s'entend pas est-ce que
tu approuve la contraception
oui
est-ce que tu as trouve la sexualité or
ma revanche
est-ce que tu éprouves l'homosexualité
est ce que tu as prouve l'avortement
pas comme méthode de contraception le
mais comme recours
détresse
oui j'ai chopé le péché mortel
alors les péchés mortels c'est quoi déjà
je me suis appliqué à oublier toute
cette culpabilisation j'ai subi pendant
mon enfance quand c est ce qu elle
consistait à envoyer au confessionnal
à confesse qu on la connaît je me
souviens très bien on était dans l'est
dans les couloirs de
devant la chapelle et on se demandait ce
qu'on allait dire et c'est j'ai copié
sur les péchés de deux camarades de
classe et je me souviens que l'on
m'avait demandé de faire quelques je
vous salue marie quelques votre père et
ensuite je me suis puisque j'ai payé
pour ses péchés je vais pouvoir les
commettre et
c'est
je ne savais pas du tout où ni l'esprit
à faire ces choses là comme deux volets
20 centimes dans la dans le
porte-monnaie de ma mère et c'est le
concept du péché qui m'a donné l'idée la
recherche de visages sont donc fausses
alors que les sept péchés capitaux
je les ai connus
tueras point ses dix commandements alors
je sais plus je confonds tout est ce que
tu pêches par orgueil
forcément on est obligé d'être d'être
orgueilleux
un petit peu par envie
celle envie qui
ce qui nous pousse à à avoir la force
d'obtenir des choses donc c'est pas mal
sous sap a péché sur sa
un bon moteur par lui qui
alors la luxure il ya
ya la morale
qui vient s'entrechoquer avec
la
l'éducation faut pas oublier j'étais
très jeune en 68 donc moi j'ai vécu la
libération sexuelle la pilule donc la
luxure
si tu es prête à tous situés à ma
personne avec qui tu es ça dépend si
cette personne ne mérite ou pas
je capable de nous soigner de l'amour
comme
si on disait que j'avais la gangrène je
serai capable de mutiler d'un membre
je pense beaucoup de gens disent je si
j'étais handicapé je préfère l'amour est
en jeu j'ai déjà failli mourir je
préfère être handicapé plutôt que de
mourir et
je préfère vivre sans la personne
que j'aime c'est négatif plutôt que
que négativement avec la personne que
j'aime je crois au bien et au mal mais
pas dans un sens forcément
religieux type jeu j'ai peur de la
religion puisqu'elle est écrit par les
hommes donc elle est forcément
écrites pour mener
une masse
pas très intelligente mais je crois
qu'on a besoin de croire en quelque
chose de plus grand que l'homme puisque
l'homme est très prétentieux et je crois
que ça peut s'appeler dieu et que je
crois que c'est bien en dieu donc tu
crois que ça peut s'appeler comme ça est
ce que tu as déjà essayé d'embrasser
quelqu'un à travers une grille de
confessionnal non même toit michaud
jean edern est-ce que tu regrettes des
fois dans ta solitude des femmes et des
enfants abandonnés bah je sais pas gelé
je regrette où la vie est un long regret
et une lente espérance eu bien sûr
toutes mes photos je les connais et tous
nos péchés je les connais
et d'une certaine manière je les aime
parce que je veux dire je me rapport et
le plaisir du repentir quelque chose
absolument sublime c'est une jouissance
supplémentaires jeudi à l'ofce la halle
la jouissance même de la confession
d'une apparente certaines fois d'avoir
des maîtresses qui ont l'âge de kaffrine
elles sont plus jeunes bon c'est à dire
pas du tout tu penses des fois que ça
pour être tout à fait
oui
oui ou plutôt ma mère mais très bien
avec tout le talent que tu as est-ce que
des fois tu ne dis pas qu'on est tout
seul avec toi même que tu es devenu un
très bon club médiatique mais un clown
médiatique quand même
je pense que notre société veut ça veut
dire que que dali picasso passer pour
des clowns et qui peut faire de temps en
temps une minute de silence en garde
le silence désespère ça finira
différence de pascal nommé frais
philippe vous vous présentez souvent
comme un titi n'est à montmartre en fête
est née à coulommiers vous avez honte de
votre lieu de naissance non mais comme
je suis partie de coulommiers alors vers
six mois
ça m'a pas tellement influencée en
revanche j'ai passé toute mon enfance et
toute mon adolescence sur la butte
montmartre dont j'ai d'ailleurs que vous
pouvez le constater gardé l'accent
vous avez honte de vos origines sociales
nombre du tout d'ailleurs elles sont
modestes n'est digne il est quoi votre
pâte à mon papa est directeur d'une
petite société
ma maman était opticienne
vous avez dit je me suis longtemps at il
s'est passé quoi depuis je me suis
réconcilié avec moi parce que je pouvais
pas faire autrement mais c'est vrai que
j'aurais voulu être autrement
physiquement autrement
intellectuellement
d'être plus pure plus dur
et que à la longue on fini par dresser
le répertoire de tous ses défauts et que
dans le même temps les qualités si elles
existent vous apparaissent moins on peut
pas prendre en grippe quelqu'un avec qui
on est condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin
et de surcroît quelqu'un qui vous
nourrit aussi bien des pères de bastien
j'ai eu peur de grossir j'ai vu que
mon accommodait bien bon je voudrais pas
devenir énorme mais c'est pas mauvais
d'être enveloppé quand on fait un métier
public ça inspire confiance à la
clientèle vous avez fait trente-cinq
mille interview à peu près et celle que
vous avez préféré c'est celle de lanza
del vasto pourquoi
prend pas ce que
c'était un philosophe
qui avait mis en accord c'est rarissime
c'est ses pensées et ses actes c'est à
dire qu'il prêchait le dénuement et il
vivait
lui-même dans une communauté
qu'il avait monté dans le sud de la
france et qui fonctionnait comme aux
premiers temps du monde je veux dire
sans aucune des ressources du programme
ils filaient lui même le lin dont il
fabriquait ses vêtements
c'est une espèce d'adage d'or et puis
j'ai vu grâce à lui quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais observée jusque là dans
la société française ou contemporaines
l'image d'un désintéressement complet
vous deviez mourir demain vous
regretteriez ne va pas vécu le côté
lanza del vasto de la vie non je pense
qu'il n'était pas fait pour moi j'en ai
deux ports ging d'autre part bon j'ai eu
une bonne petite existence de deux
journalistes
multimédia qui m'a permis d'avoir droit
à une existence à laquelle ne me
destinais
ni mes études ni mes relations ni mon
physique
sur un certain planche quand même
l'impression d'avoir tiré le maximum du
minimum
de votre faveur auprès du temps d'hier
est une classe pour dieu
il reste en filigrane de tout ce que je
fais
le regret de ne pas avoir eu la foi et
leur grève ou six grands de ne pas avoir
rencontré des gens susceptibles de me
communiquer la leur
vous le regrettez oui dis moi j'ai un ça
a été dur à vivre pendant tout ce temps
d'être le beauf de service un peu pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai joué des
personnages qui était un petit peu
caricaturaux il est une tête de français
c'est vrai j'avais une tête de français
j'avais cette moustache là
je m'étais fait poussé par un service
minitel encore espionnage était pas
passé inaperçu puis maintenant je
passais plus du tout une personne cette
fait souffrir de devoir en franche
meilleur à l'heure tous les soirs dans
les arènes de l'info canal +
oui enfin n'ont pas souffert ces images
c'est une caricature d'une image qui
était déjà une caricature quand moi je
ne faisais c'est le look lepénistes et
jane
ray avant du coup je vis dans le pénis
est plus grave que ça s'est passé
comment le jour où tu a rasé sa
moustache
tu aurais préféré avoir le succès
l'argent que tu vas aujourd'hui ou être
le sosie de thierry lhermitte par
exemple
c'est comme ça parce
que je connais tous ses défauts et
thierry
si tu devais très incarnée tu préfères
est réincarné en ou dit allen où on
alain delot
pas très amusant de jouer je ne
proviendront les rôles de jeunes
premiers sont assez chiant à jouer tu
crois que tu vas aller en enfer ou au
paradis
je sais pas bien mais ce qui me terrifie
c'est que quand je vois les gens qui
sont perçus d'aller au paradis ça me
fout un peu les glandes
tous ces gens bien pensants bien honnête
propre ça ça va être terrible en fait
les gens que j'apprécie
se retrouverait plus tôt en enfer
et si tu devais mourir ton petit arthur
savez une seule chose à lui dire ça
serait quoi
votre eau de priest s
commun je crois que kaka s'avère qu'il y
avait eu
un rôle énorme ce contexte est favorable
à la peine de mort non je mets des
queues et qui est mort jeudi n'ont qu il
faut jamais tuer qui se soigne une bête
ni encore moins un homme même pour les
assassins d'enfants même pour les
assassins d'enfants bien sûr il faut il
faudra bien lui lui pardonner il ya en
rien d'autre qui marchera mieux contre
la haine que l'amour tu crois en dieu
oui tu médites oui tu es plus tourné
vers les philosophies orientales que oui
plutôt mental plutôt et l'hindouisme
ça rit ça ça me branche plus parce que
ces sondes et des religions qui te
quitte ce n'est même pas des religions
d'ailleurs ma faim disons que c'était
sur des pratiques qui te laisse en
liberté
complète toujours t'es pas obligé de de
t'ouvrir
vide et on sent toute ta vie et de tous
les hommes et sculpteurs sur le dos pour
un jour aller dans un pseudo paradis
c'est pas ça le truc moi ça me
correspond mieux les vielles de fives
orientale parce qu'elle nous laisse en
liberté
tue en contact avec des gourous des
sages hindouiste
en contact et non mais quand on me dit
on a oui on a on a un gourou
et voilà que ccn didier c'est un gourou
écoles c'est un vrai gourou c'est une
c'est une communication avec dieu steve
mathieu c'est comme une douche tu vois
tu vas te mettre dessous c'est quelqu'un
qui a un qui n'a qui n'a plus d'ego et
quand tu vois battue c'est que c'est un
vrai qu est ce que tu es favorable au
divorce
si elle est mariée à jouer
sinon le divorce
tu sais des papiers de la paperasse
encore je suis pas favorable la
sexualité hors mariage
la sexualité il faut bien répéter avant
le mariage de toute façon mais quand on
est marié ça peut exister si certains ne
trouvent pas chez eux ce qu'ils auront
là ils vont chercher ailleurs
l'homosexualité
c'est pas moi
c'était une solution
est-ce que tu est favorable à la peine
de mort
au nom il ya tellement de gens qui sont
pour je ne peux être que contre tout en
précisant que je ne veux pas vous plaît
dans la catégorie des sadiques qui
préfèrent qui est un mec pourrissent
pendant 30 ans dans
un cachot quelconque
bien que je peux mettre à la place de
certaines personnes dont récemment
ils ont eu leurs mômes de violer tuer et
c'était un jeu bon effectivement je ne
sais pas ce que l'on peut penser à ce
moment là quand tu afficher un certain
cynisme d'un certain neil is me voir
qu'est ce que tu as des tabous tabou
tabou tabou tabou des tabous non
non pas vraiment y a rien avec quoi tu
ne rigolerai pas
c'est à dire que la seule manière de
justement ne pas en rire c'est d'en rire
parce que je crois
tu crois en dieu
je préférerais que ce soit lui qui croit
en moi
ben dieu c'est un vin vaste mot 1 il
faut croire en quelque chose
tu crois que tu y crois pas à ce vaste
monde ah oui il faut croire fin dieu ou
peut-être c'est d'ici que je sais pas
quoi dire sur moi quelqu'un qui nous
surveillent je pense que tu as un bon
père
j'ai une bonne paire mais un bon père je
sais pas quelles sont tes tabou
se dit je ne rigolerai jamais avec la
religion et le sida
c'est à dire que je rigolerai jamais
parce que ça me fait pas rire mais c'est
pas dit à bout je crois que j'ai aucun
tabou y a rien que je sais d'elle quand
on en vient d'éviter mais il ya des
choses qui ne font pas rire comme la le
sida ça fait part et parce que parce que
ça me fait peur et la religion
n'ont pas comment je vois en rire quoi
je parle j'ai plutôt content je suis
vraiment une liste quoi
c'est un pas que je crois qu'il n'existe
pas c'est que je crois que s'il est là
je vois pas sa place en tout cas je pars
parce qu' à quoi ils serviront jamais
effleuré par l'idée de l'existence de
dieu
non ça m'aide pas de savoir qu'il ya
quelque chose après que quelqu'un qui
m'attend après donc que quelqu'un qui
tue fort que j'ai besoin de savoir ça
c'est l'homme le plus fort
qu'est-ce que tu le regrette
d'abord c'est ça ouais hein non parce
que non parce que du coup je suis mon
propre dieu et j'ai pas se donne une
force ça me donne donne un caractère de
vainqueur trouve quand ton père est mort
il pas été tentés de trac rocher à
l'idée de l'existence de dieu non non je
commence cette roche concept risque
maintenant il manque maintenant sur le
coup j'ai pas vraiment réaliser quoi sur
coup c'était c'était quelqu'un j'étais
triste pour l'homme et l'agrandir la
l'autorité garder cet égard si le terme
peut énormément peur et et quand elle
n'a plus été là quelque part je mets ça
m'a aidé moi je me suis dit que il y
aurait plus jamais personne qui n'aurait
pas froid puisque malheureusement sept
personnes était plus là mais bon et
c'est maintenant par contre que je me
mets à pleurer dans un feu rouge parce
que je dis merde [ __ ] s'il était la
province qu'il m'arrive
très cher quand vous étiez petit il vous
avait réellement voulu être religieuse
oui
je devais avoir
5 ans j'étais frappé par le rituel
égalité d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie
à la maison c'était plutôt en dents de
scie
je mets la musique j'aimais l'ordonance
voilà j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand
vous dites j'ai un maître intérieur de
qui s'agit-il
je veux dire qu'à partir du moment où on
n'est pas perméable comme une éponge et
où ne se laisse pas influencer par tout
ce qui nous entoure et qu'on ne vit pas
que par rapport au regard des autres au
jugement des autres
cette voie là s'expriment vous avez
toujours préféré le terme sensualité et
sexualité tout un côté un peu outils
sexualité au fond - dont on parle et non
parce que je laisse ça aux rapports des
corps une dimension
une dimension divine
j'ai trop de respect pour tout individu
tout être humain à commencer par moi
pour considérer que le corps est un
morceau de viande est quelque chose qui
se défait qui qui pourrit et le rapport
et la jouissance le rapport d'essence et
la jouissance donne une idée plus
précise de l'extase que simplement un
orgasme un coude que comme disait mon
analyste qui laisse pas grand chose vous
avez dit nous sommes autre chose que de
la matière oui croyons dieu
le terme croire va être un terme
profane
ça à voir avec la crédulité je ne crois
que ce que je vois j'ai une sensation
très exact de quelque chose de
deux magnifiques croyons là
l'esprit oui quand vous dites qu'on vit
seul et au mur seules la solitude n'est
pas une erreur épouvantable
c'est c'est quelque chose d'exaltant
parce que la solitude ne veut pas dire
être isolé ne veut pas dire être séparés
des autres c'est être avec les autres
et si je suis conscient de ma solitude
je peux encore mieux comprendre celle
des autres et la souffrance de ceux qui
ne la supporte pas bien
merci mademoiselle bio est ce que tu es
favorables à l'avortement
moi je me suis fait avorter plein de
fois j'ai eu un enfant je sais pas si je
me ferait avorter encore avec la même
facilité dix ans
mais je trouve que c'est un droit
inaltérable la peine de mort je suis
contre je suis contre à 400 mille pour
cent quand une société aura prouvé
qu'elle a le bien fondé de juger on vous
parlera des choses d'ailleurs ce jour-là
y aura plus besoin peine de mort parce
que rapide des lignes si grave pour ça
je suis tué pour la légalisation des
drogues douces
oui je suis pour la légalisation et
l'information de tout ce qui vous fait
du bien
quels sont tes tabou
j'ai pas tabou
je dis une fois que tes héros préférés
étaient jésus-christ et pénélope est ce
que pour jésus-christ tu peux nous
expliquer
mais c'est très c'est très évident à
comprendre c'était un vrai
révolutionnaire jésus-christ jeudi en
fait le vrai martyr c'est judas parce
que jésus la halle boral et judas lui il
est finalement jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours il a le mauvais rôle c'est lui le
vrai martyr mais oui on peut très bien
voir ça comme ça ce qui prouve encore
qu'il n'y a pas
d'ombré s'il n'y a pas de lumière et
qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans la mort bien
entendu que judas était quand même la
pierre d'achoppement de la possibilité
de sacrifice du christ qui donc en étant
martyrs reste un symbole pour des
générations et des générations et des
millénaires bien entendu que judas est
quelqu'un qui est un symbole tout aussi
puissant et que l'inde vers rêver de
l'autre
retour d'un voyage aux indes tu avais
découvert le bouddhisme et tu disais que
le bouddhisme répondait à toutes les
questions qu'on se pose est ce que tu
crois toujours ça aujourd'hui oui ça
permet de répondre à toutes les
questions maintenant encore faut-il
pouvoir les mettre en acte parce que ce
qu'on pense est une chose se compensent
donc une valeur sûre n'arrive pas
l'appliquer à sa vie mais
il le dit d'ailleurs ça il dit ne crois
rien que tu une expérience si tu avais
un seul mot à dire à ta fille un seul
message un seul conseil à lui donner ce
serait quoi soit toi existe
résiste et en vie parce que tant que tu
as envie tu es en vie est ce que tu
crois en dieu
certains jours j'ai eu beaucoup cru un
moment j'ai eu une période hachée
pissier de temps dans ma vie mais
totalement naïve avec les images et les
séraphins et puis quand ces images là se
sont estompées temps en temps sur
[Musique]
je
me laisse aller à des
des idées d'infini c'est jeudi que
peintre aux physiciens
et c'est tout sont pas au but et
reviennent pas obligatoirement au nom de
dieu qui m'entraîne dans dans des
univers infiniment dans lequel on
rencontre des puissances
non identifié
est ce que tu penses que tu mérites
cette solution
je me la de notre étude favorable au
divorce
légalement je trouve ça bien que ce soit
le divorce autorisé bien sûr mais je
trouve ça pas bien que les gens dits
lourds soit à l'avortement
c'est dommage
c'est dommage qu'ils aient des
circonstances que les femmes soient
obligées d'avorter mais
il faut bien évidemment le
continuer à faire en sorte que les les
lois
qu'ils autorisent soit respectée partout
qu'il rende l'avortement
libre gratuit
il le décrit mina lisent
que ces lois soient maintenues
ou créés
à l'euthanasie
je suis fort et que chacun puisse faire
son testament et dire non mais c'est
vachement compliqué ça à partir de quand
est-ce qu'on peut décider qu'un mec
souffre trop et que s'il est inconscient
j'ai pas la question des routes et
priori je m'en fous
à la peine de mort
bah non
même pour les assassins d'enfants
ça c'est la question vicieuse et obsède
par excellence
même pour les assassins d'enfants c'est
la question piège mais quoi qu'il arrive
une société civilisée peut pas trancher
la tête un individu quoi qu'il ait fait
les tue favorable au droit de vote pour
les immigrés hu est
plutôt
est ce que tu crois en dieu non
mais je fais gaffe quand même et je me
compte du jeu mais comme disait brassens
je me conduis qui a plus mal que si
j'avais la foi
si tu avais un dernier message le
brouillard se lève un dernier message à
donner à ta petite fille ce à quoi je
verrai ça y est tu peux toucher avec à
la pêche je veux tu crois qu'on peut
rire de tout ça dépend qui coûte cher de
tous
si tu fais du mal à la personne qui
écoute elle va te dire qu'on n'a pas le
droit de rire de tout on peut pas sortir
une blague antisémites à des gens qui
viennent faire un un pèlerinage au chili
c'est pas le moment maintenant ces gens
là ils ont l'humour juif et si tu veux
leur dire des choses et ben attend
qu'ils soient disponibles
mais quand tu dis par exemple que ton
grand père a fait du cinéma qui jouer
dans le nora berra qu'il a finie
mannequin chez moi savons à ce que tu
crois qu'on peut rire de ça
dit ça pour pas qu'on oublie un jour
j'ai été voir un pote son père il s'est
occupé du film shoah celui qui a produit
et je lui dis alors ça te fait rire dit
oui parce qu'on en parle parce que les
gens n'oublieront pas
ce que tu es religieux
j'ai des coutumes
j'aime quand j'arrive chez moi un soir
de fête voir mon père et ma mère heureux
ma mère elle a préparé le dîner elle est
heureuse mon père et les chefs de
famille il en bout de table il a le
sourire on est ensemble on perd mais sa
main sur ma tête et puis je me sens
protégée j'oublie mes soucis
parce que tu crois en dieu
dieu existe les eastgate aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire autre chose que que ce
soit lui qui ait créé les hommes les
hommes qui crée lieu de toute façon il
existe mais c'est pas grave le fait quoi
te confessé
30 - les années que ça n'est pas arrivé
je pense à téter alcoolique ouais
tu buvais combien par jour
quand je me suis arrêté je lui apprenne
un avis de whisky par jour
je buvais
pour me donner du courage pour monter
sur scène ont donné le courage
d'affronter mes ennuis jusqu'au jour où
je me suis aperçu que c'est pour
l'alcool qui donne le courage de
remonter sur scène ni d'affronter les
enduits avec un peu de volonté ça va
aussi le pire moment c'est quoi ya pas
longtemps
tellement de
de pression des journal des mecs autour
qui dit juge sans arrêt
quittant tué par terre de la semaine pas
le temps de te relever
parce que depuis qu'il est arrivé des
emmerdements et qu'on gagne ils sont pas
n'ont pas laissé souffler quoi les
règlements pour arrêter l'alcool
net tout seul non seulement je roule
anglais j'arrête je me levais deux ans à
la flotte et je me suis mis deux ans à
la faute
tu craques jamais à mon nom mais je peux
pas si l'idée de prendre une cuite me
terrifie j'ai plus du tout envie de nous
réveiller le matin avec la tête prise
comme je l'avais avant
est ce que tu crois qu'on peut rire de
tout non
et quand tu dis par exemple en parlant
de ton fils qui est mort dans un
accident de moto il a trop bien imiter
coliche ça c'est sur le coup parce que
le rire est une thérapeutique que je
conseille à tout le monde j'ai même dit
en a qui ont mal tourné est le mien pas
tournée du tout à propos de cette mort
tu as dit depuis je suis en survie
personnes leur donnera mon gamin la
plaie est ouverte à vie je serai plus
jamais pleinement heureux je suis cassé
dans ces moments là t'as pas été tenté
par l'idée de trac rocher à dieu plutôt
qu'à d'humour non
non parce que je me raccroche aux gens
tu crois pas en dieu
tu pense toujours qu'il ya rien avant à
rien après comme tu le dis ça oui je
pense qu à rien avant et un après je
pense
je pense parce que même aux moments les
plus durs je les pensais pas ce que
c'était vraiment une occasion de penser
qu'il y avait quelque chose en disant
aux secours aidés -
mais même là je n'ai pas pensé tu
pouvais changer le monde c'est vrai quoi
si je devais changer le monde je me
changerait moi d'abord pourra totalement
apte à changer vous
tantum ergo s'aggrave
elle est faite
tentez d'en comme alain tocci
[Musique]
dis moi tu as dit les petits anges j'ai
mis longtemps d'en débarrasser l'enfer
le paradis aujourd'hui tu as l'air un
peu moins anticlérical écoutez moi je
suis un peu comme pascal ce fait le même
pari je ne parie sur le fait que dieu
existe tu remarqueras au passage que
c'est bien un auvergnat de pascal parce
que parier sur dieu et avec un auvergnat
qui veulent quoi tu l'appelles le hasard
dieu
tu trouves un autre nom toi c'est les
bisontins qui m'appellent le hasard mais
toile alors disons kamel alors ça tombe
très bien parce que j'ai une grande
admiration pour
la religion du gentil c'est vrai que la
bible est un livre de chevet c'est exact
tu lis souvent tous les soirs et
quelquefois le matin et en plus c'est
pas un bouquin triste très joyeux et
assez paillard ça dépend des chapeaux
est ce que finalement ça peut être
illusoire de croire que tu pouvait
échapper au p'tit jacques du collège je
suis toujours resté le p'tit jacques du
collège et les mêmes terreur je déteste
autant les adultes
je suis resté le garçon que j'étais au
pensionnat il faut pas le dire ça me
ferait du tort un dernier mot
amen
j'ai dit est ce que tu pêches par
orgueil
non
par avarice
est-ce que je pèche par avarice non par
gourmandise
ouais
parents vu
par l'ubs sur non colère ouais
pareil
non
est ce que tu crois en dieu non
je dis mon dieu n'est pas le dieu des
églises c'est lequel
non j il m'arrive de faire des prières
quand j'ai envie très forte quelque
chose arrive d'ailleurs s'arrête jamais
ses courses je devrais peut-être croire
en dieu patrie ça aiderait pas ce que je
fais toujours des prières à mon dieu
donc qui induit indéfinissable qu'est ce
qui est différent avec le dieu dont
parlent les gens qui croient en dieu
c'est un dieu un dieu
à qui je m'adresse quand j'ai envie
qu'ils mènent et qui m'a dit ça me fait
donc dit que j'avais dit que c'était pas
le bon là n'ont jamais bon je le remets
pas en question dix mois
sophie duez bio judith godrèche tulle et
choisit plutôt au giron de tes
partenaires non
je ne sais pas j'ai tourné aussi avec
balasko lavanant je ne dis pas qu'elles
soient pas gironde mais tu as dit quand
le réalisateur aime l'actrice s'est
mieux style godard karina par exemple il
ya quelque chose non plus si tu as dit
alors avec godrèche et quelque chose en
plus les quelque chose en moins
mais avec godrèche il ya le talent en
plus de tous et donc
qu'est-ce que de quoi un metteur en
scène pourrait-il rêver si ce n'est
d'avoir en face de lui une comédienne
qui a un talent extraordinaire et qui
est extraordinairement le personnage tu
refuses pas l'épithète de pervers que tu
préfères un malsain voulant dire que tu
l'as une sono paire d'heures malsain est
totalement négatif disons que malsain
c'est un pervers raté mais c'est bien la
perversion c'est comme le sait comme le
piment dans la cuisine asiatique c
dis moi me coûte est toujours aussi
obsédé par la mort ah oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr tu crois pas que si tu croyait
en dieu c'était vrai vivent certainement
ça j'en suis absolument certain
mais on ne décide pas de croire auquel
on le sait quoi
reviendront le c'est une chose qui
n'existe plus ça s'est arrêté quand en
59 compost la partie est revenue quand
jean vincent a fait quand j'étais à une
part ça il amour c'est quoi ça ça dure
maman
mais bon bah c'est formidable je suis
pas d'amour
je crois que beaucoup d'ennuis
et dieu dans tout ça ben justement ces
dunes et voilà alors que la pose et l'a
mis la main là où l'homme n'avait pas
mis les pieds donc il est très important
de savoir grimper aux murs quand on est
mieux
en dehors de ton humour excellent est-ce
que tu prends
j'aimerais bien mais moins bien mais
crois moi j'ai eu l'habitude d'être
confessé quand j'étais petit et demain
non mais obligés quand j'étais petit
parce que j'étais dans des institutions
religieuses
et c'était une des obligations ça me
plaisait pas du tout je vois pas
pourquoi il fallait que j'aille confié
un curé mes états d'âme je le fais plus
d'ailleurs c'est mon premier confesseur
depuis très longtemps cela vous antoine
wippert est ce que tu crois au péché
originel
non pas du tout
je pense qu'on est on est présumé
innocent et que le reste jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un ait prouvé qu'on était
coupable parce que tu fais des péchés
mortels en pensez seulement on pensait
j'ai déjà tuer pas mal de monde même
véritable hécatombe se souvient les
péchés capitaux est-ce que tu pêches par
avarice par exemple non non je crois pas
l'orgueil oui bien sûr c'est pas du tout
empêché l'orgueil je crois qu on fait
rien d'intéressant à revers la
gourmandise appareils gourmands disent
ces êtres vivants quand été gourmand
7ème la vie pour empêcher ça une envie
c'est un péché
c'est à dire être envieux de ses petits
copains de ce qu'ils ont mieux ouais ça
c'est pour une pensée c'est pas une
pensée très saine
j'envie les gens qui
mériteraient général les gens qui qui
sacrifient leur vie quelque chose de
supérieur et différents j'aime beaucoup
les l'idée des gens qui par exemple
partout dans les pays sous-développés
les médecins qui kiffe vraiment s'engage
quoi qui engagent leur existence c'est
ça je dois dire que ça me rend c'est
baba
dont colère oui plusieurs fois par jour
bien sûr à toi
tu es paresseux
by malheureusement je sais pas j'ai pas
vraiment le temps mais si je me laissais
aller quoi
je vais tabou
ouais
l'inceste
l'anthropophagie
et des femmes des amis
est ce que tu crois en dieu
oui de tout mon coeur
mais j'aimerais bien que ce soit ou pas
un peu plus réciproque a visité ce que
tu as quelque chose d'être reprochés
à n'ont rien du tout
à l'époque où tu faisais des films x tu
avais l'impression de commettre des
péchés utiliser un travail tu prenais ça
comme un
jeu en fait je crois que j'ai compris ce
que j'avais fait après sur le moment
j'étais vous j'étais très jeune et il ya
une sorte de naïveté d'inconscience et
et je vivais je vivais les choses comme
comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand tu
admets pris conscience de ce que tu es
et ce que tu l'a regretté
je me suis empêchée de le regretter
parce que leur gré
peut amener la culpabilité et peut donc
nous écrire peut donc nous casser des
autres donc je me suis empêchée de le
regretter c'était à refaire
mais je crois qu'il ya certaines choses
que je ne referai plus mais changera pas
tant de choses que ça je crois qu'il y a
je me suis un peu trop un peu trop
donner un peu trop gaspiller et
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui d'avoir
réussi à
effacer tout ça il ya des cicatrices qui
sont quand même pas tout à fait refermée
et qui se referme ont sans doute jamais
quels sont tes tabu
ley tabou l'inceste évidemment parce que
parce que l'enfant
l'enfant n'est pas en droit de savoir ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a besoin ce qu'il a
envie
le racisme
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se font pas raciste mais qui sont
qui sont dramatiques mais j'ai pas
beaucoup de tabous nous parce que du
gros en deux oui
c'est vrai que tu
procèdes des actions charitables dans
les hôpitaux
oui tu le dit pas trop au centre parce
que ça c'est pas c'est pas à crier sur
les toits c'est ma vie à moi et je vais
faire
comme ça sans tache tu fais vraiment oui
c'est vrai que tu est la marraine un
petit garçon indiens font parle pas
beaucoup nombreux banon
n'a pas forcément besoin de crier sont
sur les toits tout ce qu'on pense qu'on
peut faire
une maintenant si tu veux c'est une
chose que je fais parce que j'ai envie
de faire et puis c'est tout j'avoue ne
pas savoir ne pas reprendre mes jours
elle reste pas parce que tu crois en
dieu ouais
tu pries sous
tous les jours
ça se traduit comme manquantes eu pour
effet une vraie prière aussi une prière
à toi qui marie les prières dans toutes
les questions ont été posées ce soir
quelle est celle qui t'a le plus embêté
c'est que tu vas me poser maintenant
alors j'ai posé la question
comment ça se fait maintenant vraiment
pour la dernière fois comment ça se fait
que tu n'es pas je ne sois pas marié tu
n'es pas d'enfants étaient soi tout seul
sait comment c'est possible ce sont des
choses qui arrivent mais je ne suis pas
forcément tout seul c'est tout seul que
ça quelqu'un
réponde aux
aigrettes
donc c'est ça qui est embêté quand on
parle de ça et
je dois voir ma dire moi quand même sans
forcément
mentir ou autre
échec vous qui posez ces questions les
enfants les plus bas
je crois que tu était sincère soit
pourquoi payer très cher
tu crois en dieu et oui il arrive de
prier des fois oui à ma manière
d'ailleurs ça peut être dans une église
ça peut être ça peut être n'importe où
ça peut être fermement d'avis que
c'était arrivé c'était quand le privé
ça va pas remonter si loin que ça j'ai
déjà dit prier je sais pas c'était quoi
ça peut être pour enrayer le fléau de
certaines personnes qui s'abattent sur
certaines personnes à maladie les gens
qu'on aime c'est une amie qui est malade
et fait prier pour lui j'ai une amitié
mais
je voudrais qu'elle sorte de soi ce qui
est soi disant maladie cram
je pense que ça peut avoir un effet très
vite mais aussi de prier pour des amis
qui ne s'en sont pas sortis pour
longtemps
mais ça n'empêche pas apprécié
est ce que tu crois pas que
aujourd'hui dans ta carrière
tu n'es pas encore complètement débloqué
veux pas te montrer tels que tu es aux
gens et finalement c'est un blocage qui
est bloqué mais qui te nuit sur le plan
professionnel
j'ai essayé de comprendre sa de 500 jeux
une période de livres qui étaient donc
avant l'adolescence où l'âge était
spontanée après ça j'ai une belle de
bloquer par différentes avatar de ma vie
et
c'est vrai que je joue j'ai l'impression
d'en sortir un peu je pense que c'est
bénéfique évident
de ne pas tricher avec soi même c'est
tellement la meilleure solution quand on
part de ta vie privée par exemple qui
est lui toujours les questions pourront
non parce que seule la vie privée par
pratiquement comme son nom l'indiqué
elle est personnelle j'aime me garder
aussi j'ai pas envie que la rue en me
disent alors
comment ça va à côté du terrain
vous avez dit ceci ou cela est ce que je
peux faire quelque chose pour vous ça ne
regarde que moi
tu crois que tu progresses quinquin je
serai complètement libérés ou que tu vas
rester bloqué comme évidemment
non non j'espère me libérer avant soi
disant parce que je crois que je vais
vivre vieux d'apprêter
d'apprêter info ou intox c'est ce qu'on
ne souhaite en tout cas merci barry
inutile de te demander si tu est
favorable au divorce
très beau concept utile et je regrette
qu divorce y ait pas de repas aussi
copieux que devin kotoko vraiment des
noces
l'homosexualité
je suis vite égalité et non pas moi non
en face de tout ça d'une banalité tout à
fait normal absolument normal
tu as eu des expériences homosexuelles
comme
jamais j'avais mais dans le bouquin que
j'écris j'ai ralenti une folle était
bourré vous aimez trop d'eau explique
nous avons fait mais pour et je dis bien
chez vous on a essayé tous les moyens
pour et c'est absolument moi
personnellement je peux fêter mon coup
ça ne fait
jamais recommencer
est ce que tu es pour la peine de mort
des fois il a faudrait la plupart du
temps non mais des fois elle sera très
utile dans quelqu'un
dans le cas de gens qu'il faut vraiment
du mal aux autres et qui mérite une
sanction et qui peuvent récidiver
surtout cadets coeur de tout at-elle
traces de jean guy qui font du mal et
petits peuvent recommencer
quels sont les tabous ou ou qu'est venu
par plus près tout louis même l'inceste
havane ont trouvé du revenant pas tout
tout ce thème est grand mot je dis tout
ça peut être ou majuscule c'est un outil
tout ce que tu crois aux
quelque chose qui nous dépasse c'est
évident
si oui est ce que tu crois que dieu t'a
donné plus de donc à d'autres
bah je sais pas mais d'après ce que les
gens disent tout un peu plus les autres
est-ce que tu prends cinq antoine de
padoue oui l'enfoiré 18 h 1 by naim
aarab marié ma sphère trouver des tas de
trucs ou via sa page pas quelque chose
je m'adresse à lui et quand je retrouve
pas il un fait rare - et là je fais
engueuler très sérieusement j'ai fait
ici des patères des avait tout ça il
n'est pas fier est-ce que tu regrettes
pas un peu les fastes de l'église dans
le ton
non je ne te mange des quatre hommes je
trouve qu'elle a encore beaucoup trop ce
que le papa des babouches qui va les
médias et conseils comme vous faire bol
de riz ça me prend un beau un ciné c'est
la première fois que tu entres dans un
confessionnal
absolument certains croient que le curé
tutoie les ouailles
quel effet ça fait bizarre mais ça
manque de danse en deux cierges 1 c'est
pas très dansant non simple décor
heureusement la peine de mort ou aux
comptes
pour la peine de mort
pourquoi à pour éliminer vraiment il ya
des ordures qu'ils n'arrivent pas de
vivre
pour les criminels de guerre
les assassins enfants
vous n'êtes pas ça dépend des sharks
anxiété de vente et ou enfin c'est pas
contre la peine de mort a priori
gestuelle et m - par exemple du prolo
légende en herbe des immigrés ces gens
là leur tape pas si je leur trouve un
tas de circonstances atténuantes
gérant je ne me moque pas d'eux dans les
dessins
[Musique]
ce que tu crois en dieu
non
jamais cru en dieu
sait jamais effleuré
n'ont jamais un maire n'a fait baptiser
m'a baptisé je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle entre le puits terminé que
parfaite communion jamais entre eux sauf
pour admirer
qu'architecte et
non je parle je ne sens pas concerné dit
si tu me crois qu'il est en enfer ou
paradis
je crois que j'aurais dû fait par
exotiques aux frais d'épicerie par
charles
ne pas croire cette monte jamais su dès
jeudi jean dubos le métier croix sont de
la merde facilement quoi il faut que max
vous
donc c'est plus facile de croire
monsieur je crois beaucoup de trucs mais
pas dieu charlotte est ce que tu crois
en dieu oui
depuis toujours non
depuis tous
tant que je prends c'est arrivé quand
subitement qu'en quelques années le cas
l'occasion
je fais un peu du jour tout à coup j'ai
eu la certitude que c'était vrai
et que c'était même mieux pour tout le
monde je suis des listes
de la série n'était pas spécialement de
catholiques non pour moi c'est que même
dieu pour tout le monde tu crois que tu
vas au paradis ou en enfer
je crois que je vais revenir à coup sûr
terre
sais pas j'ai pas fini de revenir départ
et j'ai pas là j'ai pas eu le temps de
tout faire je peux avoir le temps de
tout faire
chacun d'eux chose que je veux faire et
je vais encore venir un couche quoi
tu revenais sur terre qu'il effectuerait
envie de faire que tu n'es pas fait
une école
j'aimerais beaucoup créé une vraie école
et vous l'école dans les enfants aux
reines et l'école que j'ai détesté nous
apprend des choses à des enfants c'est
ce qui est le mieux parce que si tu fais
des enfants heureux et intelligent ça
fera des adultes heureux interview donc
frédéric tu ne le crois pas en dieu
je pense que
dieu est peut-être
mais en tout cas certainement sous
aucune des formes que l'on nous a
enseigné
et et moi j'ai
finalement ça
c'est affreux à dire mais ça m'intéresse
pas
est ce que ton fils mathieu est baptisée
wii il est baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ah
au fait qu'un enfant a
eu
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre
de notre vie et
après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse moi j'ai préféré
celui-là
la cage maintenant il a 20 ans 21 on n'a
jamais su si c'était ton ombre et fils
ou ton fils adoptif alors c'est tout à
fait mon vrai fils c'était une
c'est à dire que c'est il a vécu avec
moi d'une manière un peu compliqué
à cause du désordre
de la jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse en
l'occurrence mais c'est mon vrai fils et
puis même s'il est témoin en fils
adoptif il serait aussi mon bref toute
façon je trouve terrible cette
différence la seule chose qui compte
c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais en tout cas
c'est mon vrai fils est ce que tu vois
toujours sa mère
non parce que
[Musique]
la droite a tué beaucoup de gens
qui l'a élevé
je les ai élevés mais pas très bien
c'est à dire que je ne me suis pas
assez bien occupé que j'étais sans doute
un peu tyrannique avec lui je lui ai
pêché de respirer quoi
et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais lui dire à
ce moment là
je t'aime
et tu favorable au divorce
ou non je pense que c'est une déchirure
quelque part qui n'est pas nécessaire
est favorable à l'avortement
je ne suis pas favorable à l'avortement
à l'homosexualité
je ne suis pas défavorable
je suis favorable à l'homosexualité à la
peine de mort
alors là non
c'est impossible de vouloir là
quoi qu'il ait fait de vouloir la mort
de quelqu'un
[Musique]
même pour les assassins d'enfants
oui parce que
dieu est le seul juge duval à metz oui
tous les dimanches non
j'y vais quand quand j'en ai envie quand
j'ai envie d'aller à la rencontre des
autres parce qu'elle a la messe c'est
aussi cela
est-ce que tu communiques ans tu vas la
baisse pas régulièrement mais eu au
minimum une fois par an
se procure quoi de communier
c'est quelque chose de très personnel
c'est une histoire c'est une affaire
entre dieu et moi j'aime bien m'entendre
avec dieu je m'entends très bien avec
lui tu lui parles bien sûr tu lui
demandes de t d non je vis demande
surtout souvent d'aider les autres
jamais eu envie de fonder une famille
je ne rêve que de ça et je n'y suis pas
arrivé
sacha distel est il favorable au divorce
non s'il ya des enfants
s'il n'est pas d'enfant
était favorable à la peine de mort dans
certains cas très précis où il peut
particulièrement quand il y as
kidnapping d'enfants assassinats
d'enfants et quand cela est fait par des
gens d'une façon évidente recommencera
la légalisation des drogues douces
ou j'ai pas vraiment d'opinion oui
pourquoi pas dans les moments difficiles
que tu as eue dans ta vie est ce que non
c'est bon là est ce que tu t'es
raccrocher à l'idée de dieu ce que tu
pris par exemple le nom je me suis
raccroché à une idée de quelque chose
dans l'au delà mais d'une façon tout à
fait inconsciente j'ai plutôt une espèce
de sens à ce mode de la dérision et
développement fantastique du sens de
l'humour qui me fait un peu passées sur
n'importe quel autre notion dit moine
est ce que tu crois au péché originel à
temps pistone à la rubrique pêcher et à
un péché qui doit être original parce
que je le fais tout le temps et qui est
que je ne vends que de moi tonnes et
jouit toujours on me dit alors le
metteur en scène ça devient antoine on
le met en scène la pièce et daniel
benoin et sept faits s'étaient produits
à la comédie de saint-etienne et alors
il faut le dire c'est le genre tu fais
confessé dans le premier budget oui oui
c'est ça il fallait maintenant
maintenant que je suis tout bien
nettoyer toute l'ue de pêcher
non ce n'est pas le péché d'orgueil
c'est le péché du bo centrisme brothers
peu d'un pêcheur si vous n'avez pas le
centriste uc voilà ouais parce que tu
pêches par avarice
annonça j'aimerais bien alors là ah
qu'est-ce que j'aimerais bien après
est-ce que tu pêches par gourmandise ah
non c'est pas gourmande non
tentant de fédérer
comme ça pas mal je me démerde non je
suis pas très bon non parce que tu
pêches par envie
d'arriver vite et
pas tout les pauvres
non ça m'est arrivé le matin par exemple
c'était l'homme
jeudi pêche par couleur
tôt rarement ça faut vraiment non je
suis pas tellement colère aux abrutis
jusqu'à poids lourds de charles darwin
et shipton parfaite charme et
orgueilleuse m'apparaissent la wii
est là
la subite après des monologues d'une
heure par coeur c'est pas de la paresse
si parce que ça j'apprends tout ça l'est
mais non non je suis fait masser comme
nick
hamm et où l'interruption de première
tout tu vois genre si je peux éviter
mais je sais pas moi de passer des
penche sur la tablette de miettes
j'éviterai tu laisses le bien sûr ah oui
tout fatwa l'appareil s'est vu quand je
pense que dans les interviews sur dix
clés mais qui laisse des millions sur la
table c'est toi qui les
désaccords mais il a calé et je
n'empêche pas il n'interdit pas qu'on
passe l'épongé un bon on passe l'épongé
ce que tu pêches par luxueux
et autres enfin le samedi
est ce que tu crois en
dieu directement dieu non mais alors
effectivement c'est au nom des progrès
de la science puisse qu'ils en arrivent
à dire que après le big bang lors la
façon dont l'univers s'est créé et
organisé ne peut pas contrairement à ce
que vous croyez moi nous ya quelques
années être le fruit du hasard voilà il
ya trop de coïncidences
c'est à dire c'est la science qui ramène
à l'est des dieux ou ou du moins de 2
quel essai d'où vient cette organisation
quoi et au diable tu crois
les diables nos énergies jamais cru même
à l'époque où je croyais en dieu tu
crois en dieu mais est ce que tu crois
au diable oui parce que je crois que
toujours la dualité entre
jour et la nuit le bien le mal et je
crois qu'on peut représenter aussi bien
les forces du mal que les forces du bien
et que c'est pour reconnaître les vrais
valeurs il faut faut reconnaître c'est
le mauvais fruits
tu parle souvent du bien que tu fais ou
du bien que tu essaies de faire partie
chansons dans le message que tu veux
communiquer est ce qui t'arrive de faire
des choses du mal
en tout cas
consciemment non mais
inconsciemment malheureusement oui mais
j'essaye de reconnaître mes fautes
lorsque je les fais lorsque je fais du
mal des fois c'est jamais volontaire
mais je peux pas dire que je suis un
100% et que je n'ai jamais fait de mal
ça c'est ça serait vraiment dégueulasse
de ma part de parler comme ça
qui est la dernière chose mal que tu es
fait
la dernière chose
que j'ai faite c'est n'avoir pas suivi
mon régime
alors en 1970 avec ta femme vous décidé
d'adopter un enfant si vous demandez à
terre des hommes
ça prend un petit peu de temps tellement
elle est enceinte elle accouche et le
lendemain pratiquement
vous accueillez l'enfant que vous aviez
demandé à un tiers des hommes aurait
dégénérée deux pour le prix d'un il sera
chassé qu'il s'agissait d'un enfant qui
s'appelait abdel qui pesait 10 kg et
qu'il y avait le monde ont soudé à la
poitrine oui qu'ils avaient creusé un
exemple l'entente avait creusé un trou
dans sa poitrine il était complètement
roulé en commun ni pour quand c'était
c'est quelque chose d'assez saisissant
avec des longs bras grêle au thorax de
poulet et facettés il était à prévoir et
on l'a recueilli dg aide t j'ai donné
mon nom non sans grand chose ça a été la
course aux médecins ça a été pour le
faire soigner et unis mais abdel seule
chose vraiment importante que j'ai fait
dans ma vie oui je peux donner un sens à
ma vie tu dis oui j'ai été trés la
période d'installation d'abdel car quand
il a été bien à la maison bien ans qu'on
l'avait bien pris en main tout ça je me
suis rendu compte que que la vie avait
vraiment insensé qu'il fallait aller
dans ce sens là il fallait
il continue et j'ai failli j'ai pas me
consacrer
créer une oeuvre de ce genre pour les
enfants abandonnés alors quand j'en
parle et c'est la goutte d'eau etc etc à
quoi je répondais que le sait en effet
que deux boutons ou quoi c'est pas et
et puis la lâcheté laine l'égoïsme a
repris le dessus en île de suez j'ai pas
donné suite à mon projet qu'est ce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui appel aujourd'hui il
est retourné dans son pays il est
il a travaillé longtemps à genève
ensuite il est allé au canada et plus
récemment il est parti en tournée en
tunisie il s'est marié d'ailleurs je
dois dit est une ravissante petite
tunisienne mais un amour de femme et il
attendait chez lui tu vois que tu
gagnais un bout de paradis avec endel et
en persan val paradis comme ça on gagne
c'est ton comment on gagne le paradis
est ce que tu regrettes ce que tu as
fait ce soir
franchement qui rit je vois pas ce qu on
a fait je veux dire on a bu un coup de
fil me répétant la même patte rapide
gonzesses on a fait presque encore un
peu quoi je puisse culture tu regrettes
fier du série pourrait tuer si méchant
parce que tu sais bien moi j'ai une
ambition quinquin qu'un but eut qu'un
désir dans la vie c'est de te ressembler
jacky est ce que tu t'es déjà confessé
oui bien en embrouille bien sûr il ya
longtemps mais plusieurs fois parce que
d'abord j'ai été élevé chez les soeurs
et j'ai fait ma communion privée ma
communion solennelle et puis enfin je me
dois dire que je suis sûr on n'arrêtait
pas de ce qu'on faisait j'étais à
l'église du matin au soir et tu feras
bleu toulouse
ça c'est une histoire terrible et de
lire jusqu'à maintenant j'aurais
peut-être été favorable mais je viens
d'avoir un cas dans dans mes relations
d'une dame qui était complètement
complètement mais
c'était fini c'était à légumes s'étaient
plus rien
réagissait plus pour un peu on allait
arrêter de la soigner il veut savoir ce
qui s'est passé d'un seul coup cette
femme est revenue à la vie elle est
réelle elle est partie vers midi elle
était alors la latitude tu réfléchis
quand même toutes pièces que j'ai eu
tort est ce que j'aurai tort est ce que
c'est
ça la durée fléchi vraiment pas comparer
et tu fais vraiment la peine de huy ah
oui les hommes qui ont les femmes qui
ont la halle à l'audace le la cruauté de
martyriser des enfants dont les tuer de
martyriser des vieillards delà de
l'étude alors là oui tout de suite
toutes les meilleures je discuterai même
pas y aurait même pas de gros serrières
tout de suite oui
est ce que tu crois en dieu oui et je
suis obligé de parents dieu parce
qu'étant grâce à 16 ans j'ai eu un très
grave à de 6 ans je suis tombé de 7
étages par la fenêtre et je suis là s'il
n'y avait pas eu le bon dieu je crois
que tous vous verrez certainement pas
croyable
non
non je pense pas je pense que les gens
qui sont très méchants très enfin ça
j'espère penser à ça sont punis dans la
vie oui il ya un juste retour des choses
sales on retombe sur le nez oui c'est
pas si si le diable autre chose mais oui
je veux croire à ça
si je devais partir là
et tu ton fils michel à côté de toi y
ait un seul mot à lui dire tu dirais
quoi si je vais mourir il dirait je
t'aime je t'aime je ça a été toute ma
vie voilà je vais dire est démise toi
qui tu as prête à faire une tournée des
cathédrales tu n'es pas surpris de te
retrouver dans un confessionnal ah non
pas du tout moi j'ai visite souvent le
monastère chinois en grèce et j'ai des
discussions longues avec les moines sur
beaucoup de choses de la vie donc ça
prouve que je suis un croyant jeu pas
très pratiquants d'ailleurs mais les
cathédrales les ou quelque chose de
mystique de magique et c'est un vieux
rêve que j'avais et c'est pour ça je
vais faire presque toute la france en
chantant des chants de noël des chants
religieux et puis quelques chansons de
mon répertoire qui s'apprête bien dans
ces lieux
on a vu qu'à une expérience mystique de
15 à 19 ans
est ce que tu es aussi attirés par le
paranormal tu as dit si je voulais je
pourrais être médium pourquoi tu veux
pas
parce qu'on est tous des médiums ya pas
certains gens qui ne sont plus que les
autres certains gens qui jugent qu'ils
ont et qu'ils ont été exercés plus que
les autres ce dont tu crois en la
réincarnation en 1976 qui disait être la
réincarnation d'alexandre le grand jeu
c'est vérifié commence battue c'est nous
les grecs on est tous un peu alexandre
des connards tous un type et alexandre
le grand est du genre bad en nous comme
chaque espagnol et le type est donc qui
cote
en 1987 cette fois tu étais convaincu
être un ancien far as
tu choisi pas mal et j'ai vécu un ancien
l'egypte je vécus au moyen âge et
je pense que je vais plus avec alexandre
avec alexandre des grands macédonie et
mais je me cherche toujours
parfois tu dis aussi être un soldat dans
l'es7 d'angleterre et être moore d'un
coup de lance dans la gorge et tu dis
que pendant le temps où tu as été pris
en otage par les terreaux et si j'adore
ce ressenti une violente douleur dans la
gauche oui ça c'est vrai
ta grand mère c'est vrai que tu la vois
des fois derrière toi et elle est
toujours là et moi même ma grand mère
paternelle
et je la vois aussi tu l'as vu ce soit
ce soir non pas ici il ya trop de est
trop de vibrations entre de trop
d'énergie trop de s'il y avait quand
même la pause forcée électrique se soit
laissé et je ne sais pas si c'est dans
toutes les émissions des danses et là je
suis sûr qu'ils en avaient
donc les bons esprits viennent pas dis
moi gérard ya une question que je
voulais te poser quand même pourquoi tu
débarques toujours les émissions de télé
là tu débarques chez dechavanne là ce
soir tu j'ai débarqué dans mon émission
qu est-ce qui c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est le deuxième point je voudrais pas
devenir le spécialiste de ce genre de
chose
en général disons que c'est par par
solidarité la première fois c'était pour
lorsqu'elle est cette espèce de
nazillons visio nice tu es là ce soir
c'est quoi j'ai pas compris la nouvelle
à ce soir c'est comme ça une couleur une
leur ai envie de niveau anti chez toi tu
regarde la télé puis d'un seul coup tu
t'habitues prends ta bagnole et tu viens
pas de façon systématique mais
voilà c'est la deuxième fois
bon écoute maintenant c'est à moi tu te
confessé oui ça te va comme réponse sous
12h samba oui qu'est ce que tu me dises
saison c'était spontané c'est un acte ça
se finit bien sûr vu
c'est une pulsion
est ce que tu es favorable divorce
oui
ce qui serait une femme avec deux trois
ans quand
j'ai quitté une femme avec un enfant
qui penche dès fois
a toujours
oui non oui j'y pense que la vie ne lui
ça m'empêche pas de les revoir et
d'avoir élevé la fille bon je me suis
marié j'ai divorcé
l'euthanasie qui seraient d'accord
dans l'absolu
on doit l'absolu oui pour avoir été
confronté à deux trois cas comme ça
désespérer totalement
désespéré donc
oui mais c'est un problème très délicat
de suicide
oui oui y'a pas commenter le suicide
j'ai pensé à se suicider toi
non pas vraiment
mais pour les autres ça te fait pas peur
il n'y a pas de pas de peur à avoir pour
les autres je pense qu'on est je pense
que
c'est aussi une certaine façon une
certaine façon à donner un prix à sa vie
que se suicider
c'est une espèce d'ultimes le pouvoir
qu'on l'a de vie et de mort de sa propre
vie de sa propre mort
gelé oui je rentrais est-ce que tu est
favorable à la peine de mort
non pas du tout je suis contre la peine
de mort et surtout en chêne pendant dix
ans mais si ta fille on vous avez
quelque chose à ton enfant et tout ça je
suis contre la peine de mort
même les assassins enfants
même pour les assassins d'enfants et
d'une façon un peu plus anecdotique je
pense que je ne pourrai jamais partagé
une seule idée de
le pen
donc à partir du moment où il est à ce
point pour la peine de mort même si
j'étais totalement ignorante de ce sujet
même si cela ne concernait pas je serai
de systématiquement opposés parce qu'ils
pensent le contraire
si c'est très clair tout ça s'y est dit
favorable à la légalisation des drogues
douces
oui
cordoue ça veut dire quoi m
shittu soit maintenue ouais
je sais pas s'il est totalement d'accord
pour enfin bon
oui je pense que ça changera pas trop le
problème
il ya ya ya ya un certain nombre
d'exemples lalal hollande l'espagne
quelques pays comme ça
ça n'a pas trop bouleversé le paysage
politique j'allais dire de ces pays tu
crois en dieu oui
ce sera du moment
j'essaie de vivre ça au quotidien
c'est à dire que je ne suis pas
pratiquant
je suis je suis juif au cas où tu ne
serais encore pas donc je ne suis pas
pratiquant
mais plutôt que d'attendre des fêtes qui
ou pardonne nous et ça vous colle aux
caisses gc ou au quotidien de de
comprendre d'être le moins banal et
médiocre possible
et de donner un maximum
c'est de la façon dont elles à moi d'y
croire
tu crois au diable
ah
bah oui une vérité une contre-vérité
certainement
oui oui
équilibres internes avis quelle forme il
prend le diable aujourd'hui tout
tout ce qu'on est en train de faire un
diabolique
la conception de
de cette émission est diabolique dis
donc robert quand tu étais petit la
confession t'as pas mal donné non quand
même
oui j'ai cru à samoa mais peut-être j'y
retournerais cette année il paraît que
depuis deux jours ces défunts dont on
peut la dîme à elle au lieu de mon père
voulait davantage et donc c'est pour
gagner ton paradis tu as fait une
chanson dédiée à jean paul 2 qui
s'appelle pat music
non mais c'est parce que j'avais été
bouillie versifiée par le fait que le
plus nous qui était puisque je fais pas
de l'humour qui étaient rentrés par son
envie était vraiment sorti par le trou
de balle et jouent avec ça méritait
d'être immortalisés sinon ça c'est un
personnage comme on dit que je trouve
relativement sympa parce que même si
inventorié y répète des bonnes choses
mais aussi tant d'amour ouais mais vous
par contre hull 6 c'était moins fan tu
raconte que ta mère tu l'a amené à rome
on est par le pas points etc en fait
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé avec
beaucoup de gens quand est arrivée la
balle a perdu la foi a compté le
commerce quand elle a vu que pas
seulement l'élévation séjours et des
photos du pape au lieu de baisser la
tête elle a perdu leur foi ma mère avait
réciter le chapelet toute sa vie et est
pratiquante à la la la mais ce non
seulement dimanche mais quelquefois les
épaules c'est le premier chantier très
mal chanter est flatté je n'ai pas
tellement savoie et deuxio sais que ma
mère qui cherchait le bon dieu n'a vu
que des flashes de kodak et que des
hommes aimant en or elle s'est évanouie
et depuis que je n'ai amené au vatican à
rome et n'a jamais pu remettre les pieds
dans une église catholique je sais que
je fais de la peine à des gens qui
croient à quelque chose me demander la
vérité mon père vous l'avez tu vois que
le régent peu le doute à main je crois
qu'elle aurait trouvé sympathique mais
c'est en même temps un symbole d'une
espèce de paralysie mental s'est emparé
de l'univers sauf que mieux vaut voir
des gens suivent idolâtrie quelqu'un
comme jean paul 2 que dès que des
méchants dit que son équivalent en noir
qui émettrait des ondes négatives donc
si quelqu'un je discute pas
pourtant de toi tu t'es pas mariés à
l'église saint tudy mari dans une
chapelle kitchener mini chapelle blanche
à las vegas
avec la
ça se passe
je me suis mariée à las vegas c'est un
mariage valide parce qu'on veut quand
même à l'hôtel de ville on donne notre
notre est aussi fier de tout ça et là le
le pasteur m'a demandé où voulez-vous de
la musique en boîte ou de la régie je
veux pas de musée que ça me rappelle mon
bureau mon travail tout sonne ensuite il
nous a varié ceinture exactement trois
minutes et demie après c'est une seule
année quatre rouleaux de 25 soupe pour
aller jouer au lady luck même si on a eu
droit une bonne pizza et puis il ya
place à du champagne stade du bébé doc /
ça a été une des grandes déceptions de
mariage une femme était malade
est ce que tu es faible sexualité hors
mariage au mariage ce que tu trouves ton
ferme ou
non parce que j'ai l'avantagé d'avoir
épousé une femme coeur vous dit ce qui
est obsédé sexuel comme moi alors pas de
danger que ça valait la peine de mort
tout peine de mort là je trouve qu'on
devrait choisir mais quand quelques la
demande la peine de mort l'on devrait
lui donner
parce qu'à être 25 ans d'aléas les
barreaux ou bien tu mens ça doit être
les prisonniers devraient avoir le choix
est ce que tu fais avant de légalisation
des drogues douces et oui quand
l'égalisation du porno ça disent des
choses que moins on a enfin comment dit
on a mieux qu'on n'en parle plus de ces
choses là mais plus et les galets et
moins on a un par les mois on vide d'en
consommer parce que ce qui était
formidable dans les années 60 avec les
drogues douces c'est que c'est un terme
10 avait un petit côté l'évolution sur
tout le monde en a autant que tout
d'abord mais un grand principe tout ce
qui est fut ma bhl abîme les poumons et
donne un cancer du poumon donc mieux
vaut boire de la bière blanche que de
fumer quoi que ce soit tu fumes putois
fumer un peu de nicotine web ont joint
de temps en temps mais il soit très très
très très bon parce qu'il ya des clubs
là dedans comme dans l'est lorsqu'on me
demande si tu crois en dieu tu dis je
sais pas je me demande si si c'est pas
une réminiscence de beaux l'éducation
quand je dis mon dieu aidez moi tu te
demandes si c'est pas finalement ton
éducation qui t'a marqué tu sais pas si
tu comprends du bain et je suis un
stoïcien shintoïste revisionner
s'attarder de gauche mais surtout pluri
t on ce sens que
j'aime adoré la nature les poissons
le soleil la lune je trouve que ça
c'est ça qui me enfin tu m'inspires qui
mêlait vers le haut qui m'inspire la
beauté mais mon idée de dieu c'est la
relation
l'interrelation qu'il y entre les ags de
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment en
iran mais cette espèce de deux doigts
alors je peux pas le définir mieux que
ça le
l'interrelation
interactions ses sauts dieu pour moi il
le dit appuie croix non je voulais aller
en enfer la semaine dernière il paraît
que sa prose au feu non peupliers les
personnes tu veux toujours être enterré
dans ton pialoux banon j'ai déjà un pied
dans la bien
au delà pour déconner
c'est la plus grosse connerie que ce
soit dans ta vie
je sais pas
ma plus grosse
j'en sais rien quand il était marié est
ce que tu penses que tu a tout fait pour
garder ton mari ouais
ouais
[Rires]
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que tu ne
referait pas qu'est-ce que je referai
pas depuis le début de ma vie
je crois que veut jeune je serais allé
voir le en fait le premier garçon dont
j'étais vraiment amoureuse et que je
serais allé lui montrer mon amour sans
orgueil son me drapé dans un orgueil et
la con et je suis allé lui dire que je
l'aimais vraiment et je l'aurai pas
laisser partie voilà pourquoi tu vas pas
feu parce qu'il est mort maintenant que
j'ai pas eu le temps et j'ai été congelé
pas face à tanger attendu et puis mon il
ya eu çà
tu crois que c'était lui et l'homme de
ta vie
non je pense je pense pas sinon il
serait pas moi ou alors je serais morte
aussi non j'ai enfin tous les cas
j'espère pas parce que c'est dans ce cas
là ma vie est foutue
et puis si je pensais vraiment que ça
avait été l'homme de ma vie je pense pas
je me serais mariée peuple
tu es amoureuse en ce moment
donc on en voit en photo dans les
journaux avec un acteur américain fait
charmant hôtel mais pourquoi parce que
parce que parce qu'on va trouver ma vie
privée en la jetant en pâture au public
alors que j'étais pas d'accord je suis
d'accord de de donner un certain un
certain nombre de choses qui
m'appartiennent mais quand on vient de
les voler je suis pas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas envie de
répondre à cette question cette histoire
là j'ai envie de la préserver et j'ai
pas envie qu'on ne me l'a gâché avec des
photos des cdd des photos de paparazzi
des choses comme ça tu crois que tu vas
être mariée
mais j'espère à 20 ans ça dommage de me
dire voilà ma fille c'est terminé pour
toi tu as plutôt à marier oui j'espère
que je me remarier
ils voient comment nos 20 ans non
maintenant je me vois sereine avec toute
ma famille autour de moi dans une dans
une maison dans un dans un endroit où je
me sens bien avec avec des rires partout
c'était une baguette magique tu ferais
quoi comme métier j'avais une baguette
magique
chanteuse de hard rock un bon
tu t'es déjà confessé guy bah oui comme
tout comme tout bon chrétien à mon jeune
âge dans ton jeune âge pas vraiment
parce que tu as été baptisé à 17 ans
quand ton frère s'est marié on l'aimé
j'étais croyant avant le baptême n'est
qu'une transition c'est un acte écrit
mais ça veut rien
aujourd'hui tu as été en fait ne rompt
pas vraiment je crois quand même il ya
des choses supérieur qui nous régissent
forces du bien et du mal un jour je te
vois un jour je te vois pas
je crois que la véritable dieu c'est
notre conscience que tu crois pas la
résurrection par exemple je crois pas à
la conception du saint-esprit non c'est
déjà du mal là j'ai du mal à franchir ce
pas c'est un peu ton facile de croire
que mais cela dit
le message laissé par le christ est une
un message de qui mérite quand même
d'être
suivi approfondi respecté
et on peut pas le nier quoi mais c'est
un peu pâle liaison dix mois maintenant
tu au confessionnal avec moi oui oh non
pas qu'elle est la plus grosse connerie
j'ai fait dans ta vie le jour où j'ai
été
m'installer le dans la campagne de
giscard d'estaing
qui se passait du côté de la porte de la
villette dans les rôles dans le hall des
abattoirs et oui il y avait moi j'étais
venu comme ça ben c'est un petit mais
pas particulièrement
guidée par l'amour que je pouvais porter
à giscard d'estaing et le hasard a fait
que quand ils m'ont vu arriver y mit
immédiatement dirigé vers l'estrade
la plus importante celle où il y avait
les invités de marque et où précisément
à la place qu'on ait quitté alain delon
pour faire son discours mais surtout il
a bombardé par tout le monde j'étais
viré trois jours après ça a été dit
rhéaume au moment où tu as été viré par
à partir des groupes tu vois tu as
vraiment pensé à se suicider à ce moment
là j'ai pas été heureux non je peux être
reçus retour de la part de des groupes
dont il était certain que j'avais été un
de ses acolytes en 68 quand on voulait
tous refaire la france et quand j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer
mitterrand quelques années plus tard
quand il mène deux ans plus tard
impressionnant fin sommes un an et demi
plus tôt même métier ramadi mais vous
savez mon chéri lui que vous êtes un
professionnel de la politique ne compte
pas dans notre profond dans votre
profession par contre ceux qui courent
devant les roues et je voyais bien de
qui vous voulez parler et bien je
l'aurais jamais rien demandé et ils
courent devant les roues voila voila
c'était ma consolation est assez minime
par rapport à la lan et demi de placard
que j'avais connu 10 - la connerie qui
est amenée en taule même si un an plus
tard tu as été disons éclaircies de tout
soupçon là tu laves est pas celle là se
dire que si je regrette de ne pas m'être
rendu deux autres fois de suite à la
convocation du juge d'instruction est
d'ailleurs le seul jour où j'ai quitté
le palais de justice j'ai dit à tous les
journalistes qui étaient là et
d'ailleurs je lance une petite pierre
dans le jardin des journalistes de tous
les médias c'est que pour ma sortie de
taule comme pour mon entrée judo en
première page pour ma relaxe et mon nom
lieu j'ai eu droit la 14e page de trois
lignes je te trouve parfaitement
incorrects et dégueulasse de la part des
journaux s'y
joue tu mourras ya ton fils à la roche
ça approche
je te trouve encore très enfants et ton
fils qui est là tu es une chose à lui
dire tu dis quoi et a fait le métier qui
me plaît c'est de bien le faire mais
celui là si tu devais prendre là le
sillon que j'ai tracé ce serait bien ce
qui malheureusement pas le cas pour
l'instant parmi toutes les personnes que
tu as cassé dans les médias ce qui n a
plus aujourd'hui à qu'ils étaient en vie
de demander pardon et laquelle je casse
pas pour le plaisir de casser je dis ce
que je pense et des fois ce que je pense
c'est cassant mais c'est pas pour faire
de la peine
je dis ce que je pense des gens voilà et
dans un métier où ça se fait pas
vraiment ça peut surprendre
mais pourquoi tu as côté un peu fouillis
mais franchement entre nous
c'est pas fou il maire de o sens presse
à scandale vraiment c'est que ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la nature humaine
les faiblesses des gens connus c'est une
façon finalement de démystifier
peut-être un peu les gens connus parce
que les gens connus c'est avant tout on
est connu c'est des gens et ça passe par
ces questions là ce que tu veux
démontrer bah ça passe par des questions
intimes parce qu'effectivement c'est
dans l'intimité que tout le monde et le
plus semblable tu dis souvent enfin tu
me dis souvent qu'il faut pas trop
déconner avec la religion parce que toi
qui rit tapper de bruyants en enfer
franchement en tirer tu serais pas un
peu con
c'est vrai que c'est un peu con de dire
il ya deux choses que je respecte c'est
le roi elle pas bon ça semble un peu
bizarre on dit ça pour donner un genre
c'est du marketing en fait je crois pas
vraiment je crois que moi j'aimerais
mieux qu'ils aient un roi en france
c'est vrai c'est sincère là aussi ça ne
fait pas que des amis ce truc là parce
que pour les français après 200 ans de
propagande républicaine ils confondent
un peu louis saez adolf hitler quand
même quelque part donc ça ne fait pas
que du bien ce truc là le pape c'est
pareil pour moi la personne que je
préfère au monde c'est le pape et
surtout celui là alors j'aime pas qu'on
rigole avec la religion d'abord parce
qu'on tire pas sur les ambulances je
trouve que c'est un peu facile de faire
l'anticléricalisme il ya 90 ans qu'on en
fait
je suis sans doute un peu con oui de
croire que que si je suis pas gentil sur
la terre que si je fais du mal je vais
en enfer brûlés dans des flammes ça
c'est un peu con mais on peut appeler ça
le karma j'ai pas envie d'avoir un
mauvais karma voilà ça c'est déjà un peu
moins con le dire comme ça non
si ton père débarqué là sur le plateau
comme sacrée soirée où la conscience
d'arthur tout à l'heure tu lui dirais
quoi
je dirais que c'est un peu grâce à lui
que je suis là parce que je crois qu'il
voulait être journaliste et il n'a pas
pu et que en tous les cas on a toujours
donné le goût de la presse de l'info de
la vérité je crois que toutes les
vérités sont bonnes à dire c'est quelque
chose qui lui qui comprend
je crois que je dirais ben voila tu vois
simple c'est pas seulement parce que tu
es mon père que je suis là c'est aussi
parce qu'en 54 tu m'a fait écouter
europe 1 matin alors je dirais merci
mais pas seulement d'être mon père
quelle trace tu m'as laissé à pas ta
disparition j'aimerais rester comme un
empêcheur de tourner en rond mais pas
uniquement parce que j'aurai dix ans qu
à t d et qu'est ce que tu aimerais que
tes gosses 10 de toi tu es fini
je sais pas j'aimerais qu'elle dise que
j'ai été un bon père mais j'ai pas le
sentiment que je suis tout le temps
tellement je bosse quoi donc j'aimerais
qu'elle me pardonne et qu'elles disent
d'accord on l'a pas beaucoup vu mais il
a fait des émissions de télé qui était
pas trop mal il a fait des bouquins qui
était pas trop mal il a fait des gens
n'osaient pas trop mal voilà quelle
excuse mon absence par deux trois
conneries que j'aurais laissé coi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu